here's what I think of when I hear that
again the word pragmatism comes up
because you're talking about well what's
the use of it what's the point of it
so then I'm wondering well is is reality
or theorizing tied to pragmatism in some
sense yes because we're finite beans we
have to choose to do something but then
can we not philosophize for the sake of
philosophizing so that's what occurs to
me and then at the same time when saying
well we don't know if these Chinese
dragons are playing football in some
other dimension that never interacts
with us however I would say it's still
firstly it's fun to think about Chinese
football playing Dragons and second
just like we were talking about in the
beginning scientists have an aversion
are generally now contemporary
scientists have an aversion to
philosophizing they would say well this
is much of what you're talking about
especially when it comes to metaphysics
is unfalsifiable science is a
methodology let's apply that let's stick
to our mathematics but then you were
making the great argument which is
that leads us to plenty of places even
if it seems misleading at first or even
if it seems to not interact with us
first
so that's what else I think about it is
that okay even if we say there are these
non-interacting Chinese dragons that
play football
okay let me hear you out do you truly
believe that do you have some great
Arguments for it let's hear it okay
let's think about that would this be the
case of that and then you can arrive
someplace interesting so I'd say
first you said it's about a point what
is the point what is the use then I say
well that's pragmatist that's pragmatism
in this sense of it has to have a use to
us and I'm saying well we could talk
about that but then also at the same
time there could be a use in the sense
that well we can talk about
incomprehensible unfalsifiable Notions
and still lead us somewhere propitious
in the long run okay so that's what I
think now I say that and I'm curious
what are your thoughts on what I've just
said
well um I I wouldn't not disagree with
you
um
I think there is a tradition in
philosophy
so let me develop something I hinted
before there's a tradition in philosophy
which is to warn
philosophy has a cure Wittgenstein is a
master of that cure against wrong
questions
uh we're wrong what does wrong mean here
uh you probably called me a pragmatist
if you say wrong it's useless
um
so uh
like not good for us ultimately leads us
astray but as humans
um yeah so just take us to the wrong uh
to to the wrong uh
if if you stay in science science was
often liberated uh by philosophical
thinking
that science often made Step Ahead
by getting input from philosophy that
said well you don't you don't have to
ask this question
um uh certainly
displayed around
Copernicus but play bigger role in
Einstein Einstein got from Mark the idea
that uh the asking the question of uh
what it's really really meaning of two
things happening at the same time it's
just a wrong question we forget about
that that's not meaningful I mean and uh
also from Heisenberg took the idea that
the electron doesn't have a position at
any time directly from this is a this is
a wrong you're you're imposing a
so there is a there's a traditional
philosophy just warning uh uh against
the wrong kind of questions and uh
I I think what I'm saying here what I'm
trying to say here is that uh
um it's a the notion of reality is good
uh because we we use it to distinguish
the the chair in the mirror from the
chair
um on which I can see it to distinguish
the Dream from the from what I see when
I'm awake this clearly what is a what's
in a play or in a novel from what is not
in a playing a novel is future or or for
distinguished I mean you tell me that
yesterday you met John and said is that
real or false you lie that's it's
meaningful this is a we know exactly
what you mean by real and false here
um
but then if we take this notion of real
and we make it uh
extrapolated
to say everything we see is not real
uh because everything we see uh has a
level of Illusion of some kind much
weaker kind of the mirror much weaker
kind
uh it's good that we realize that
there's a level of Illusion but then we
are postulating that there is a
underlying reality behind that and that
postulation might be wrong uh simply
wrong or at least it's let's put it this
way it's remarkable that size failed to
get to that Ultimate Reality so far so
why should we expect it we what is the
rules about reality I mean Quantum
Fields I mean we don't even know exactly
what is a Quantum field because of the
complication of quantum mechanic we know
what it's a classical field
um
quantity is something that manifests
itself with particles okay but particles
are not real
so we are confused on the Ultimate
Reality even in contemporary physics
um in contemporary physics today
uh not to mention about in philosophy in
general what is Ultimate Reality matter
energy God Spirits language
everybody comes out with a with an
Ultimate Reality story and and failed to
convince the others
um
so
the perspective I find it
uh
interesting is to de-emphasize
the notion of Ultimate Reality
and interesting interesting interesting
and use the word reality at level by
level like with this it's surreal that
there's a chair there but it's also real
that that chair is some illusory thing
it's also real there's just a bunch of
atoms those things are two
and within its contest something's real
something is it's also we can add
content add levels in which is a better
understanding of reality
uh without getting trapped and oh my God
we don't have access to reality we don't
have access to reality that's a chair
okay I'll explain my thoughts what
occurs to me and then we can get the
rapid fire questions and answers just
from the audience because you've been so
generous with your time thank you
Circle
absolutely okay
this has been a very philosophical
uh take little physics little Loop
quantum gravity this is very very good
that's about I get basic philosophy of
science and physics understanding and
the nature of reality let me
recapitulate what you said so I make
sure that we're on the same page there
are different ways that we use the word
reality just like there are different
ways we use the word time and just like
there are different ways we use the word
almost any noun essentially depending on
the context so let's imagine we can put
these contexts in separate boxes much of
the confusion occurs when we think
well we mean
well much of much of miscommunication is
we intend it to be from box a but you
perceive it as from being from box B so
the contexts are mixed up
and what I was wondering is when it
comes to reality even within the same
context
I don't see there being an internally
consistent even within the context and
by the way you mentioned Wittgenstein
Wittgenstein had this notion of language
games I believe the language games would
be the equivalent of context here boxes
I'm wondering if there's an internally
an internally consistent notion of
reality
okay so well
and then where was I going with it ah ah
okay now my
what I think is at least I haven't seen
any and anytime I try to come up with
well I haven't seen any internally
consistent definition of reality
now there are a couple answers to that
one is
the Donald Hoffman method
forget it so it's there's no reality
it's all unreal in some sense then
there's the phenomenological answer the
phenomenology answer which is actually
all you experience is real it's real to
you even if you're schizophrenic you see
a snake in front of you that's real to
you
but then you're you actually took a
different route which I never occurred
which is
please stop using the word reality just
let's forget about it so am I making a
correct summary and if I'm interested
yes yes yes
uh please stop uh using the word reality
uh unlabeled and uh
divorce the context reality I mean use
use the word reality in each context
so
it's like we should have reality sub a
really sub B yeah and make sure
in this movie this is real this is real
this is false
but that's a movie it's all false in in
a different sense of will so the the the
the the realize it's a variety of
meaning in the context in which you uh
in which you you use it so in a context
we
give me a context and I I give you a
much better definition of reality okay
in the context of the miserable written
by Victor Lugo I can absolutely uh
uniquely say what is real and what is
not real what is real is what's written
the book it's not really what you act
it's not written the book okay in the
context of the history of the United
States
it's absolutely real maybe when we can
make a mistake but we know that to make
a mistake so we know what is real is not
real that you know George Washington
announces becoming a king whatever
whatever happens
um so context by context we have a with
a clean notion of of reality which
allows us to make distinction
um
between real things and not real things
it's a unique what real reality to
reality real not real outside all
contexts which I think is dangerous
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy